[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا وهذه نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء نبدا بالعناوين
الملك سلمان والرئيس الصيني واقعان على
اتفاقيه الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين
البلدين
ولي العهد السعودي والرئيس الصيني يشهدان
التوقيع على اتفاقيات بين البلدين وترقبوا
قمتين عربي وخليجيه مع الصين
[موسيقى]
نجاح الوساطه التي قادها ولي العهد
السعودي ورئيس الامارات لتبادل سجينين
اثنين بين واشنطن وموسكو
بعد احباط انقلاب الرايخ داخليه المانيا
تدعو لاعاده النظر في المؤسسات الامنيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم البدايه من السعوديه وقمم الرياض
حيث وقع الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز مع
الرئيس الصينيه
اتفاقيه الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين
البلدين هذا واستعرض الملك سلمان مع
الرئيس الصيني بحضور ولي العهد على قناه
الصداقه التاريخيه بين البلدين وسبل
تعذيزها في شتى المجالات
كما شهد ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان والرئيس الصيني على توقيعه عدد من
اتفاقيات التعاون ومذكرات التفاهم من
بينها خطه مواء ما بين رؤيه المملكه 2030
ومبادره الحزام والطريق كما وقع البلدان
على مذكره تفاهم في مجال الطاقه
الهيدروجينيه وتشجيع الاستثمار المباشر
وشملت الاتفاقيات المواقع كذلك مذكره
تعاون في مجال الاسكان واخرى خاصه بتعليم
اللغه الصينيه
[موسيقى]
وكان ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان عقد جلسه مباحثات مع الرئيس الصيني
في قصر اليمامه بالرياض واعرب ولي العهد
السعودي في بدء المباحثات عن ترحيبه
بزياره الرئيس الصيني الى المملكه
وعقب وصوله الى العاصمه السعوديه
الرياضيه ستفتح عصرا جديده لعلاقات بلاده
مع المملكه والعالم العربي واشدد على
مواصله الجهود للارتقاء بعلاقات الشركه
الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين الصين والسعوديه
على مستوى اعلى وزياده المواهمه بين
مبادره الحزام والطريق ورؤيه 2030 واضاف
الرئيس الصيني
والعربي لبناء المستقبل المشترك نحو عصر
جديد لافتا الى اقامه الصين علاقات
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله مع فتاه
عشره دوله عربيه وتحقيقهم انجازات وصفها
بالايقونيه والخارقه في شتى المجالات هذا
واكد جيم بينج المضيق قدما لبناء علاقات
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الصينيه الخليجيه
والتي تشهد تطورا سليما ومستقرا وفقا
تعبير
من جانبه اعلن وزير الاستثمار السعودي
خالد بن عبد العزيز الفالح توقيعه 35
اتفاقيه مع الصين واضاف ان الاتفاقيات
الموقعه بين المؤسسات السعوديه والصينيه
شملت قطاعات ادى بينها طاقه والتعدين
النقل وسلاسل الامداد كما تضمنت قطاعات
الخدمات اللوجستيه وتصنيع المركبات
والرعايه الطبيه وتقنيه المعلومات
[موسيقى]
هذا ويتوافد القاده العرب للمشاركه في
القلمتين العربيه والخليجيه مع الصين في
العاصمه الرياض حيث وصل الرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي وولي العهد الكويتي الشيخ
مشعل الاحمد اضافه الى رئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد شيعه السوداني ورئيس مجلس
السياده السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان
والرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس وعدد من
القاده والزعماء العرب والرئيس الجيبوتيس
اسماعيل عمر جيلاله
لمتابعه اكثر ايضا عن هذه القمم الحاصله
في الرياض نذهب الان الى هناك وزميل
العيال اختيار وضيوفها اليك ليال
شكرا لك يا ميسون مشاهدينا نقعد معكم لهذه
التغطيه للقمم التي تعقد في الرياض من
العاصمه الرياض سينضم الينا الان
بالاستوديو الاستاذ جاسر الجاسر الكاتب
الصحافي والاستاذ محمد زاهد رئيس تحرير
اندبندنت التركيه سابدا معك استاذ جاسر
اليوم امام اعاده تعريف العراق العلاقات
الدوليه ان كان الصينيه بمفهومها الاقليمي
والدولي وامكان السعوديه تحديدا بمفهومها
مع القوى العظمى ومع القوى الصاعده مع ما
شاهدناه اليوم من توقيع اتفاقيات من مؤسسه
للمرحله المستقبليه كيف يمكن لهذا التعريف
ان يكون شكله المرحله المقبله
اولا انا بذكر نقطه يعني اعتقد مهما لا
نقل الصوره والشخصيه السعوديه في في
اليومين هذه المملكه والامارات ساهموا في
اطلاق السجناء بعمليه تبادل بين الروس
والامريكان وهذا عمل انسان يقوم ويعبر عنه
وطبيعه اشتراكات الموجوده انا ليست قطبيه
وليست احاديه ايضا المساهمه السعوديه في
دعم الاقتصاد التركي والمصري بالودائع
وهذا الدليل نعمل كشورها في المنطقه ولا
نعمل بشكل فردي وانا بالتالي نخلق حاله
التعاون المشتركه لتحقيقه اهداف التنميه
التي تستخدم المنطقه اليوم مثلا في
المملكه تم توقيعها استراتيجيه همم
الشامله بين السعوديه والصين انا اعتقد
هذه الاستراتيجيه اليوم كل الاتفاقات التي
وقعت هي جزء من هذا النتائج نتكلم على
مرحله التحول بحيث يكون ما يشبه اندماج
الشركات في العمل انك تتحول تعمل على شكل
واحد وبيقاع واحد لماذا لانه التوافق في
انه قاطر مشتركات تاكدت ان العلاقه بطبيعه
الروحيه والوديا قائمه ومتينه نوعيه تراك
نوعيه الثقه ونوعيه التعاون فتحدث اليوم
الاتفاقات التي وقعت اليوم هي مجرد حاله
مراحليه هنتكلم اليوم على الشراكه الشامله
على مدى 20 و30 سنه قادمه في كل التفاصيل
من البحث العلمي والتعليم والثقافه
والرياضه استاذ محمد اليوم الانتقال من
مرحله التحالفات الجامده الى مرحله
التعاون المرن ويعني التكامل بين الدول
الاقتصاديه الثقافيا على كافه الصلح كيف
يمكن ان يؤسس الى منهج جديد للعلاقات
الدوليه بالمرحله المستقبليه وتكون
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي من فتحت هذا
الباب
يعني بامتنع ان نتحدث اولا عن
عالم كان احادي القطب اليوم يتم الحديث عن
عالم متعدد الاقطاب وعندما نتحدث عن عالم
متعدد الاقطاب لا نقصد هنا بالضروره
تحالفات جديده ضد كما اشار الاستاذ الكريم
قبيل القليل ليس بالضروره ان يكون فلان ضد
فلان او كما كان يقول بوش الابن من لم يكن
معي فهو خصمي وبالتالي هذا المنطق حقيقه
الذي كان يسود العالم بان لنقل الان اعتقد
انه بدا يتم تاسيس لنظام عالم جديد وخاصه
اننا نتحدث في تونس ازمه عالميه كبيره همم
فيما يتعلق بالغذاء فيما يتعلق بالطاقه
فيما يتعلق في فتون همم الازمه الاوكرانيه
والتي هي تجلياتها حقيقه نشهدها في كل
المنطقه
اليوم يعني هي اكثر مرحله همم ركود
بالنظام العالمي لا يمكن الحديث عن ان
النظام العالمي خلق او او يعني اصبحنا
نعرف ما هو شكله استاذ جاسر الصين اثبتت
بالفتره الماضيه انها ليست مجرد قوه
اقتصاديه قوه بشريه اا قوه ديبلوماسيه بل
انها قوه العقل والانتاج والرياضه ودول
المنطقه ايضا اثبتت عبر نجاحاتها انها قوه
الانتاج والعقل والرياضه بكل على كافه
الصعد الالتقاء بين هاتين القوتين كيف
يمكن ايضا ان يؤسس الى شراكه قويه
بالمرحله المقبله هو التحول العربي اللي
في المنطقه العربيه يعني من بدايه رؤيه
المملكه وبالتالي تحولات الرؤيه الحالات
الاستقلاليه العرب سابقا كانت تقول اذا
قال الطفل تلعب مع من فهو تابع واذا قال
من يلعب معي فوق قائد اليوم الدول العربيه
بهذه المنظومه تشكيليه تكون من يكون شريكي
انا هذه خطه هذه اهداف هذه التصوراتي هذه
محاكم من من سيكون معي الصين هي الاقرب
الصين الاقرب لاسباب كثيره البعد عن
التجاذبات السياسيه
لاهتمام في عمل التنميه والازدهار
والاقتصاد ولذلك تدخل ليست صراحه فبالتالي
احنا بدنا نتحدث عن الصراعات تتحدث عن
تحول جذري في عمليه التعاطي وعمليه اعاده
البناء وتشكيل والرهان على المستقبل ندخل
مع الصين لان الصين ايضا ماضي في المستقبل
لا ندخل في التجاذبات السياسيه الاشكاليه
لليوم من مزايا الحقيقه اللي كسبتها الصين
اولا انه المملكه تعقد القمه العربيه
الصينيه وبالتالي تعطي السن دفعه قويه في
المحور الدولي كحله اعتراف الجانب الاخر
لان نقول انه زياده الضغوط الاوروبيه في
المساومه في التعاقدات والتعاملات ومن ما
يخالخلخل الثقه وبالتالي الحاجه في
التنميه المستقبليه الى راحه واستقرار
وهذا الاستقرار يتوفر مع الصين ايضا الصين
تطمع انها تتقدم وتحقق برنامج
استاذ محمد يعني المعلوم ان العلاقات
الصينيه السعوديه ليست بالجديده هو شيء
كررناها منذ اسبوع الى الان انما الشيء
الاساسي بها انما اسس له بما يعرف باللقاء
الشهير بحديقه السفاره بواشنطن بدانا يعني
نلمس ثماره اليوم ما حصل اليوم من لقاءات
ومن قمم ستحصل تباعا ايضا في الغد كيف
ستؤسس لمرحله جديده بالفتره المقبله
هي علاقه ممتازه وفيها شراكه اقتصاديه
بالدرجه الاولى لكن هذه الشراكه بامكاننا
ان نسميه
شراكت بائع ومشتري اكثر منه في البعد
السياسي والابعاد
الاقتصاديه الاخرى التي يتم الحديث عنها
اليوم بمعنى اننا نتحدث عن اكبر شريك
للسعوديه اقتصاديا الصين لها مشتريات
باكثر من او قريب الاربعين ملي نحن نتحدث
عن شريك ايضا للصوم في منطقه الخليج ب 160
مليار دولار تقريبا هذه الارقام لا شك
انها ارقام كبيره اليوم نحن نتحدث عن
مواءمه بين خط الحزام ورؤيه 20 30 نحن
نتحدث ايضا عن وضع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في المسار استثنائي في خط الحرير
نتحدث عن موانئ نتحدث عن مكان السعوديه
تتحول فيه الى هب الى مركز اساسي لتصدير
المنتج الصيني هذا الامر حقيقه لا شك انه
سيعود بالفائده لكل المنطقه العربيه
والخليجيه لكن من المؤكد على الصين ان
تدفع بعض الاثمان السياسيه اذا ما ارادت
الاستمرار في هذه الشركه اليوم الشراكه
الشامله حقيقه التي يتم الحديث عن انا
اعتقد انها يجب ان يكون فيها ترجمه لبعض
المواقف السياسيه
بهذه النقطه تحديدا والبعض يعتبر بان اساس
العلاقه الروسيه السعوديه هي اوبتك بلس
ولكن ما هو اساس العلاقه الصينيه السعوديه
اليوم هل هو الموضوع الاقتصادي التنموي
وايضا بالموضوع السياسي روسيا موجوده
بكثير من الملفات السياسيه بالمنطقه هل
ممكن يعني الانقراض في المنطقه ان يجعل
الصين مجبوره ان تدخل ببعض ملفات سياسيه
كما حصل مع روسي
من هذه الجانب السياسي وهذا ما يطمئن في
التعامل مع الصين والبعد وعدم التدخل
والعدم يعني القطبيه السياسيه ليس هناك
ليس هناك يعني هذا التوتر او تشنج او في
او في الاخره في المقابل التعاون
الاقتصادي الارث اللي متكون من العلاقه
على مستويات المختلفه اطمن معنا تراه من
85 احنا صارت تفارق التعاون الاقتصادي
بشكل ولم يكن هناك علاقات انا اعتقد انه
مات هذه الروح بين البلدين بشكل اليوم
الصين نرتاح نطمئن مستقبلها نطمن نتغير بس
ليست هنا الى تقلبات حزبيه او سياسيه
وليست تروج افكار تفرض على ولا تتدخل
عسكريه بتالي في مساله تحقيق التنميه هذا
مكسب كبير وبالتالي السيد السيستم هذا
الجانب وايضا السعوديه ومعه الدول العربيه
تستثمر هذا الجانب الموضوع همم الموضوع
الصيني الايراني الذي يعني حكي عنه الكثير
هناك نقطه اعتقد بانها هي النقطه الج
وهري وهو ان هناك تباين واضح بالنظره لحتى
لبلوره النظام الدولي وحتى للطاعاتي مع
القضايا الاقليميه والدوليه وحتى لمفهوم
النموذج بيننا همم ايران وبين الصين
وبالتالي لا يمكن الرهان على ان اللقاء او
ال- العلاقه بين هذين الطرفين ممكن ان
تؤثر على علاقه سيمبل منطقه بالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه هل توافق على هذا ذلك
ارجو ذلك بمعنى احنا لم نسمع من الصين مره
واحده ادانا صريحه للهجمات الارهابيه التي
استهدفت المملكه العربيه السعوديه من
الحوثيين
هذه هي المشكله هذه هي المشكله مع الصين
هي همم حتى بعض المواقف الرسميه التي يجب
اتخاذها من الشريك من الصديق لم تقوم بها
وبالتالي كونها تتوافر على علاقه اليوم
جيده في ظاهر مع ايران المرجو المطلوب
منها حقيقه دور سياسي بهذا الخصوص حتى
يستطيع الجميع ان يشهدوا عمليه تنميه
وتطوير في المنطقه نحن اا في السابق دعنا
نقل الكل كان يعول على الدور للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والغرب في
يعني
تكبيح يعني اقول جناح ايران وهيجاماتها في
المنطقه
واحتلالها لاربعه عواصم عربيه وغيرها من
الامور
حتى هذه اللحظه المواقف الامريكيه
المرينا لم تاتي بشكل واضح رغم ان كلا
الطرفين على في السياسه على طرفين نقيض ان
تاتي بثمار ملموسه منتجه وبالتالي اليوم
الصين اذا استطاعت حقيقه ان تتحرك في هذا
الملف وهذا انا اعتقد المرجو عربيا
وخريجيا في هذا السياق اذا استطاعت ان
تتحرك في هذا الملف بحيث ان من النصر الى
نتائج ملموسه واقعيه على الارض انا اعتقد
هذا اهم بكثير من ما يمكن تسميته بالعلاقه
والشراكه الاقتصاديه التي نتعم نتحدث عنها
الانصالح والمملكه ولي العهد الملك كانوا
واضحين بهذا الموضوع باكثر من مرحله ومن
يعني محطه عالم تحكمه المصالح وبالتالي
هناك علاقات نديه وعلاقات متساويه هذه
العلاقات المتساويه اليوم مع الصين بين
المملكه والصين بين الصين والدول الخليجيه
والعربيه يعني غيرت بمفهوم العلاقات
الدوليه بين الدول كيف يمكن ان تغير وتؤسس
للمرحله المقبله المملكه تعمل على اساس
نعمل في ما نتفق
نحترم الثاني يمكن اختلف بنفس ما في
مساواه ليس ليس هناك ليس مطلوب من الصين
انها مقابل هذه الشراكه الاستراتيجيه تدفع
ثمن في قطع علاقات العراق نامل ان يكون
هناك مساهمات لكن هذه منفصله نعمل في
الثقه في هذا الجانب نحترم خيارات الدول
الاخرى قراراتها توجهاتها مصالحها الاخرى
ليست مقننه هذه الارتباط ليس ارتباط حاسم
هو ارتباط يقوم على المنفعه المشتركه ماذا
نخدم بعض وكيف نستفيد من بعض وكيف ندعم
بعض وكيف نحقق التنميه المشتركه وكل ما
يستفيد ولم يشكل القلم والاستمرار وتعزيز
مثل الشراكه هو ان ليس هناك قلق سياسي من
مساله ما يطرح النفوذ الصيني النفود
الصيني
ولو كان هناك قلق من المشاريع الصينيه في
المنطقه لكن هناك موقف سياسي لكن نشعر انه
في هذه النقطه نحن كنا نتقارب ونتفق ونعمل
شراكه لتحقيق هذا بدون قلق من مخاطر
سياسيه او ضغوط سياسيه او هيمنه مستقبليه
اليوم يعني الصين قدمت نموذج اقتصادي نامي
لديه عناصر عناصر متكامله ان كان العناصر
سياسيه المتكامله ان كان الاقتصاد
الانتاجي المتكامل وهي اصبحت لاعب اساسي
يعني بالسياسه الدوليه بهذا القرض هل ما
حصل من قمم من انفتاح خارجي من تغيير
بالسياسات الصينيه على مدى العقود الماضيه
ممكن ان يماسس لان تكون الصين عامل
استقطاب لاسياسات الدوليه بالمرحله
المقبله
المراقب للسياسه الصينيه كما تفضل الضيف
قبل الخليل كانت تقوم على السياسه
الاقتصاديه بالدرجه الاولى وهي دوله الان
مرشحه لان تكون بعد سنوات قبائل تتربى على
عرش الاقتصاد الدولي كاكبر اقتصاد في
العالم وبالتالي اذا ارادت حقيقه ان تتربع
على هذا العرش انا اقول انها يجب ان تدفع
بعض الاثمان السياسيه وليس بالضروره قطع
العلاقه مع دوله اخرى لا اتحدث عن قطع
العلاقه مع ايران بالعكس اتحدث عن توسط
وضغوط همم تستطيع ممارسهها اكثر بكثير من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على ايران
وبالتالي اذا كانت حقيقه نصين تريد ودا
عربيا تريد شراكه حقيقيه عربيه لان
فعليا الان منطقه الخليل
والمنطق العربي لديها شركات حقيقيه مع
الدول الغربيه مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ومع روسيا وغيرها وغيرها
وبالتالي ما الذي يميز الصين لان تكون
شريكا حقيقيا هل فقط هي علاقه بائعه
ومشتري ام نريد ان نتجاوز هذه الشراكه
الحقيقيه اللي هي بائع ومشتريه ونتحدث عن
مئات المليئه عشرات المليارات بالمئات
المليارات من 160 مليار في منطقه الخليل
نريد ان يتجاوز هذا ونضاعف ربما هذا الرقم
لكن بناء على معطيات جديده معطيات
يستفيدوا منها الطرفين معطيات يفيد السلم
الدولي معطيات نستطيع ان نقول من خلاله
بيته هناك عالم متعد طب اصبح هناك قوى
اقليميه حقيقيه مثل المملكه العربيه
السعوديه التي اصبحت حقيقه بوابه للغرب في
قمه بايدن في قمه جده بايد ان اتخذها منبر
لمخاطبه الخليج ومخاطبه العرب واليوم
الرئيس الصيني يتخذ ايضا الرياض منبر
اساسيا للشراك العربيه
بطبيعه الحال
السياسات
الامريكيه بالمعايير الدوليه الامريكيه
مقابل ذلك
تنمويه انفتاحيه عدم تدخل بالسياسات
الداخليه وبالتالي اسست يعني لمفهوم جديد
في العلاقه بين هذه الدول اليوم مقابل
هذين ان نموذجين تحقيق التوازن بين الشرق
والغرب هل هو صعب على دول المنطقه المنطقه
بدات تاخذ المبادره بدات هي تتغير بدات
التحول من حاله التبعيه الى حاله
الاستقلالليه والعمل ليس فقط في القرار
السياسي العامه على تقنيه مقومات الاساسيه
لتصبح مستقله بالكامل يعني المملكه اليوم
تعمل انها تكون مركز السلاسل الامداد في
المنطقه وتعمل على العمل ان يكون هناك
تراك في بناء مقبول مات حقيقيه تغذيه
الدول سواء الصناعه او من حيث الزراعه او
من حيث التغذيه بالتالي العمل لا يكون
قائم فقط على هذه المواقف يقوم على همم
يعني همم ابعاد اللي او يعني رفع القوه
الذاتيه مقابل القوه السلبيه السابقه نعم
اليوم احنا المشكله الغربيه نعتقد الخساره
او الضغط الغربي في مساله انه فرض معايير
معينه
والمساومه في هذا الجانب احنا نرجع نقول
المساومه المساله خطيره خل الثقه وتخلف
قيمه والحلاقه وتؤدي الى انعكاسات سلبيه
وهذا ما يحدث وبالتالي الصين تحصد ثمار
السلوك الغربي هي لسه ولكن اليوم موضوع
همم انه الصين تحل مكان الولايات المتحده
كل اعداء المملكه بهذه المرحله
الاعلام
ان الولايات المتحده اليوم بمرحله ضبط
نزاع مع الصين بسبب الازمه الاقتصاديه
العالميه وبسبب تبيعات الحرب الاوكرانيه
وبالتالي ايضا المنطقه هي بمرحله تطوير
علاقات تنويع علاقات بموازات كل يعني ضبط
النزاع العالمي لماذا التصويب على هذه
العلاقه وتناسى العلاقه الاخرى لاننا هل
هذا سيؤثر على ما يحدث على الارض مع انثى
الارض لا لا يلتفت ولا يتاثر عمليا بمثل
هذه الموجات هو ان جاءت من مصادر السياسيه
كانت في البيت الابيض او من وسائل الاعلام
وجهه نظر وموقف معين احنا نتكلم على تغيير
تغيير حدث على الارض ويتحقق ويقوم الزياره
حدثت اشارك الاستراتيجيه الشامله اعلنت
بخطواتها مذهله والقمه العربيه قائمه غدا
بن معطيات التي تكون اذا هنا هناك حركه
تمضي في سياق مختلف
تؤثر هذه الحمله لما كانت تستمر وهي مستمر
ليه اسباب عديده من قبل هذا مجرد تمره وهي
انا اعتقد ان حاله من حالات الحسره خاصه
في القطاعات الصناعيه والشركه الغربيه
التي تخسر بسبب مواقف السياسيه
النمو المتوازن بالمرحله المقبله خصوصا مع
قل يعني النظام العالمي مع دخول الاقتصاد
العالمي بمرحله صعبه وبمرحله مختلفه اليوم
تحقيق التوازن عبر هذه الشركات
الاستراتيجيه التي بدات اليوم وستتكمل
بالغد الى اي مدى هو مهم لدول المنطقه
هو الشيء الاساسي في اطار ضمن رؤيه 2030
يعني بالامس كنا في المؤتمر
الصحفيين لوزير الماليه الذي يتحدث عن
ميزانيه همم 20 23 هذه الميزانيه اذا ما
قررناها بميزانيات اخرى السعوديه مشابهه
في السنوات والاعوام الماضيه سنعيش يهدوا
فيها الكثير من التغيرات سواء في اطار
اداره الموارد والتنوع الذي حصل حقيقه
بشكل واضح وبارز وكذلك الانتاجيه التي
وصلت اليها المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
قطاعات متعدده مختلفه يعني مثل هذه الامور
حقيقه التي اتت هي نتائج الرؤيا رؤيه 20
30 بشكل واضح اعتقد انها ستتكامل وستتطور
بشكل واضح مع هذه الشركه التي نتحدث عنها
الان يعني هناك كما اشرت همم هناك مواء
انا حقيقه بين الرؤيا وبين المشاريع التي
تريد الصين تاسيسها في المنطقه بشكل
والسعوديه بشكل خاص وبالتالي ربط كلها
بالرؤيه كلها بطبيعه الحال
سيعكس بشكل مباشر ايجابيات وليس فقط على
المملكه العربيه السعوديه واقتصاده بل
سيعكس بشكل ايجابي على اقتصاديات المنطقه
بشكل عام
الانفتاح الصيني السياسات الصينيه
المتوازنه الخارجيه التي بدات بالعقد
الماضي وبين الاشتراكيه الحديثه التي تحدث
عنها الرئيس الصيني بمقاله اليوم كيف يمكن
ان تتغير العلاقات الصينيه العربيه
بالمرحله
التي تحضرها يعني ممثلين منظمات دوليه هي
كانها شكل يتبلور لخلق تكته الاقتصادي
والسياسي جديد مثل المنتدى التعاون
الاقتصادي مثل بريكس مثل تشكله الجديد نحن
نجمع هذه الاصوات هي اليوم تتحدث من مصالح
مشتركه سياسيه واقتصاديا وتمويا وتعمل على
مواجهه تحديات مشتركه وبالتالي السن تدخل
فيها الطرف فيها اشاركه فانا اتكلم على
صوره جديده من العام المشترك قد يكون قريب
من الاتحاد الاوروبي مثلا قد يكون كالموي
ولا نتكلم على تحالف عسكري او تحالف سياسي
تتكلم على بما يحقق يخدم هذا في المنطقه
فجانب الاطراف اعاده جلب الاطراف الكبرى
الى المنطقه حينما حضر بعيدا كان النقاش
ماذا تحتاجه الدول العربيه وماذا تريد منه
امنيا وتنمويه وحينما يحضر غدا الرئيس
الصيني كان الطلب يكون ماذا تحتاجه وماذا
ممكن
يعني شكل العلاقات بين المنطقه والقوى
العالميه قائمه على التحالف العسكري
التحالف الاقتصادي من الباب النفطي ما
ادخله ما ادخلته السياسه السعوديه الجديده
السياسه الخليجيه الجديده هو مبدا التنميه
بالعلاقات مع الدول ومع الدول العظمى هل
يعني هل هذا سيجعل همم التعامل ويعني
الرهان على اي تنازل مقبل الدول العربيه
بالمرحله المقبله صعب جدا
في الاطار نحن الان نام الان ترتفع دائره
الدول العربيه التي داخله في المنظوم
التنموي والتطويلي بعض الدول تواجد سكلات
سياسيه بعض الدول تواجدك اقتصاديه في
مرحله يعني المخاض والتحول اذا نجحت في
ذلك ترتفع الدائره نعم ستدخل وليس فقط
الدول العربيه نحن نتكلم ايضا على
ارتباطات قد تصل الى امريكا اللاتينيه
اعاده تشكيله هويه عالم جديد يقوم على
المصالح وعلى المنفعه وعلى الشراك
الحقيقيه وليس على التبعيه والاستغلال
العلاقات سافتح اخير بما اننا باخر دقيقه
بين العلاقات العربيه الصينيه تركيا اين
بهذه الشراكه بما انك همم معني بالشانت
التركي
ابتداءا استطيع ان نقول ان تركيا ده حقيقه
على نفس هذه الفلسفه منذ سنوات في
سياساتها الخارجيه
على الاقل جاد عربيه وتركيا دلنا لن لنقل
وقبل ومصريه ايضا يعني في اطار فتح
فرص جديده فتح نوافذ جديده في السياسات
التي تم الاعتيادها خلال ربما اربع خمس
عقود سابقه يعني نحن شهيدنا قمم متميزه
بين تركيا وروسيا شهيدنا قيمه متميزه بين
الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي وروسيا شهيدنا
القمم متميزه ايضا مصريه صينيه ومثلها
ايضا شهدنا قمم تركيه صينيه بالتالي هذه
هذا التوازن يشعر الجميع بضرورته حتى
الوصول الى تحقيق المصلحه المرجوه لهذه
البلدان شكرا لك
على وجودك معنا وشكرا لك ايضا استاذ محمد
فهد رئيس تحرير صحيفه
شكرا لكم مشاهدينا الى هنا الى ختام هذه
التغطيه لليوم من الرياض للقمم السعوديه
الصينيه السعوديه او الصينيه العربيه
والصينيه الخليجيه طبعا غدا سن نكمل هذه
تغطيه سيكون هناك ايضا اا طوال النهار
تغطيه من اتجاهات العربيه بالرياض الان
اعود اليك ميسون شكرا لك يا ليالي
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا نذكر بهذه الاخبار العاجله ولي
العهد السعودي للرئيس الصيني اجتماعنا
يجسد عمق الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين بلدينا
وايضا نسعى لدفع الشراكه بيننا الى
مستويات اعلب سنتابع في التاسعه هذا
المساء بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الروسي يؤكد مواصلات ظهر بالبناء
التحتيه الاوكرانيه للطاقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا قبل ان نبدا مع
ملفاتنا الاخرى في التاسعه هذا المساء
نعود ونذكر بابرز ما ذكره ولي العهد
السعودي للرئيس السنيق قال بان العلاقات
بيننا تبتسم بالصداقه والثقه المتبادله
ايضا تحدث بان اجتماعهم عمق الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه بين البلدين وايضا تحدث ولي
العهد السعودي للرئيس السوري وقال نسعى
لدفع الشراكه بيننا الى مستويات اعلام
وبان شركتنا تسهم في حفظ السلام والامن
الدوليين هذه ابرز النقاط التي تحدث عنها
ولي العهد السعودي للرئيس الصينيه سنتابع
الالمته حقيقه خارجيه السعوديه
والاماراتيه عن نجاح الوساطه التي قادها
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
ورئيس دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده
الشيخ محمد بن زايد وقد اكد بيان السعوديه
الاماراتيه مشترك ان نجاحه وساطه تبادل
السجناء تعكس علاقات الصداقه امريكا
وروسيا واشار البيان الى ان ابو ظبي
استقبلت الامريكيه بريتنينغراينر عبر
طائره خاصه قادمه من موسكو بالتزامن مع
استقبال الروسيه فيكتور بوت عبر طائره
خاصه قادمه من واشنطن واضح البيان السعودي
الاماراتي المشترك ان عمليه التبادل
السجناء بين موسكو واشنطن تمت عبر مطار
ابوظبي كما اعرب البيان وعن شكر المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والامارات العربيه
المتحده لحكومه امريكا وروسيا للتعاونهما
لانجاح وسلطه تبادل السجناء
اليوم
من المكتب البيضاوي هي امنه وعلمتني
الطائره في طريقها للديار بعد اشهر من
المفاوضات مع الروس التي مرت بظروف صعبه
بين محبيها ما كان يجب ان تبقى هناك
لوحدها بريتني طلبت مني الا انساها
وامريكيين اخرين لمساعدتهم على نيل حريتهم
والعوده لاهلهم نجحنا في اطلاق سراح
بريتني ونعمل على اطلاق سراح امريكيين
اخرين
[موسيقى]
الى المانيا وبعد ان احبطت السلطات واحده
من اكبر المخططات الارهابيه اعدته جماعه
اقصى جميل للانقلاب على الدوله دعت وزيره
الداخليه الالمانيه الى اعاده النظر عن
قرب المؤسسات الامنيه في البلاد ومدا
اختراقها من جماعه اقصى اليمين فيما توقع
مسؤولون المان اعتقال المزيد من الاشخاص
فيما يتعلق بخطه المزعومه لاقصى اليمين
للاطاحه بالحكومه واكد رئيس الشرطه
الفيدراليه في المانيا سنه 54 شخصا
محتجزين قيد التحقيق بينهم شخص نصب نفسه
اميره ومظلي متقاعد وقاضي جزء عم ان
المؤامره دبرها اشخاص مرتبطون بما يسمى
بحركه مواطن الرايخ التي ترفض الدستور
المانيا بعد الحرب وشرعيه الحكومه
[موسيقى]
الى الحرب في اوكرانيا هكذا رئيس روسيا
لازم تفوت على بلاده صوت واصل ضربتها
بالضرب
فعلا على الهجمات
بجسر القرم وهجمه اخرى قامت بها اوكرانيا
منذ انطلاق الحمله العسكريه الروسيه لم
تشهد مناطق الشرق الاكرانيه هكذا تصعيد
القصف المتبادل بين القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه وصل دورته ما دفع بقائم اعمال
رئيس الجمهوريه دونيتك الانفصاليه الى
تعليق العمل والطلب من مواطن مدينه دمياط
لعدم الخروج وبحسب السلطات المحليه
للمدينه كان لافتا ان صواريخ الاوكرانيه
تسقط بالاسواق الشعبيه وتدمر المرافق
المدنيه ما يشير الى ان القصف عشوائيه
كحيلنا يتركزوا القصف الروسيه على المناطق
المحيطه بدون نت مثل
ما زالت قوات باكنير الروسيه تطوق المدينه
من الناحيتين الجنوبيه الشرقيه والجنوبيه
الغربيه في محاوله للدخول الى باخمود
وواسطه دفاعا شرسا من قبل الجيش الاخراني
[موسيقى]
قبل ان اتابع مع الملف الروسيه سنعود
لزميلتنا في برلين مناسبه العربيه راغب
برنامج نعرف منها تفاصيل ما يجري الان في
المانيا رغده اهلا بك معنا ما هي
الاجراءات الان ولماذا هذا التخوف من قبل
الداخليه على المؤسسات الامنيه واعاده
النظر بها عن قرب
اهلا بك يا ميسون لانه يعني هناك على
الاقل او هناك جناح مسلح في هذه المجموعه
التي تم القبض عليها او تم الكشف عنها
معظمهم من الذين كانوا من شيء او قدماء
الجيش الالماني هناك عضو واحد على الاقل
كان عضوا فعالا في القوات الخاصه
الالمانيه لذلك هذا يسلط الضوء بشكل كبير
على مدى اختراق الجيش الالماني من قبل
اليمين المتطرف وما اذا كانت فعلا
الاجراءات الامنيه او الاجراءات همم تدقيق
مع الاشخاص قبل قولهم في القوات المسلحه
هي اجراءات كافيه ام انها غير كافيه ويجب
مراجعتها يعني اعتقد اكثر في افكار
المنتمين الى الجيش والافكار التي
يحملونها ما اذا كانوا يحملون الافكار
اليمنيه متطرفه او متطرفه باي شكل همم وما
هي الخطوات التي يجب اتخاذها من هنا
الكلام ليس فقط الذي صدر عن وزير الداخليه
كان هناك كلام شبيه بالامس من حزب الخضر
الذي دعى جلسه في البرلمان لمناقشه هذه
النقطه ااا تحديدا وايضا يعني كان هناك
انتقادات من مسؤولين في الجيش ايضا تحدث
عن ضروره ان تكون هناك اجراءات يعني امنيه
مكثفه اكثر للتدقيق في المنتمين للقوات
المسلحه شكرا لك من برلين مراسله العربيه
على هذه التفاصيل والمعلومات
وسنعود مشاهدينا الى موضوع روسيا فالكسب
الحرب مع روسيا وحسمها الان اوكرانيا هي
بحاجه الى ثلاثه اسلحه بعد ان الحلقه
سلسله من الهزائم الكبرى لموسكم مؤخرا
تقول مجله نيوزفيك الامريكيه اوكرانيا
تمتلك القدره والاراده لاخراج القوات
الروسيه من اراضيها والفوز لكنها حقيقه
تفتقر الى المعدات العسكريه اللازمه
لانهاء الحرب بسرعه خبراء عسكريون
بريطانيون اكدوا للمجال الامريكيه ان
تسليحه اوكرانيا بالدبابات والمدرعات
الثقيله من شانه ان يساعد بهزيمه روسيا
وجود هذه الدبابات والمدرعات يجب ان
يتزامن مع وجود اعداد كبيره من الجنود
وهذه العمليه تسمى التنقل المدرع اي ان
المركبات المدرعه والدبابات يجب ان تعمل
معا في عمليه مشتركه لانه في حال عملت هذه
الدبابات انه الفرده ستكون عرضه للاستهداف
من قبل القوات الروسيه وهنا نتحدث عن 1000
دبابه بالاضافه الى المركبات التي ستحمل
الجنود كي تنجح هذه العمليه الان ما هو
السلاح الثاني الذي تحتاج اليه كاف هو
صواريخ بعيده المدى التي طلبها
الاوكرانيون مثل مثلا اي تي اي سي ام اس
سيسمح للاوكرانيين بضرب شبه جزيره القرم
واخراج البحريه الروسيه منها سانتقل الان
الى ثالث الاسلحه فهو تسليح القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه وهو امر بالغ الاهميه لحسم
الحرب ايضا لماذا لانك ركزت في الاشهر
الماضيه على القوات البريه وايضا على
الدفاع الجوي ايضا على اكياس ان تختار بين
المقاتل الامريكيه من طراز اف 16 او
المقاتله السويديه صعب
فهذه الطائرات القتاليه
ستصنع الفارق بين انتهاء الحرب او
استمراريها
[موسيقى]
في التاسعه هذا المساء سنتابع
بمحاكمه صوريه ايران تعدم اول متظاهر
ومنظمات تحذر من تنفيذ مزيدا من الاعدامات
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات الحاصله في ايران حيث شهدت
ادانه واسعه بعد اعدام متظاهر يبلغ من
العمر 23 عاما وهي اول حاله اعدام ينفذها
ويعلن عنها النظام الايراني خلال هذه
الاحتياجات الجاريه اسره الشاب محسن شكاري
طالبه المتظاهرين الايرانيين بالانتفاضه
للسائر في ما كتب نجم كره القدم الايراني
السابق علي كريم ردا على خبر اعدام شكاري
مخاطبا السلطات في بلاده انتظروا الانتقام
لاعدام محسن شكري بدورها دعت منظمات
حقوقيه ايرانيه الى الكشف عن مصير العشره
من المحتاجين المعتقلين الذي يرفض النظام
الكشف عن مصيرهم بينما تتخوف اسارهم ان
يكون مصيرهم كمصير محسن شكاري اي الاعداء
[موسيقى]
انا المشاهدين بعد انتهاء اضرابات الثلاثه
ايام التي عمت نحو 60 مدينه ايرانيه
بدءا طبعا من العاصمه طهران التي رفع فيها
المحتجون شعارات التظاهر في بعض محطات
المترو وايضا في حافلات النقل العام في
الطرق المؤديه الى شارع ازادي وانقلاب
بالعاصمه اضافه لمدن ذات الغالبيه الكرديه
والبلوشيه والاذريه ومن المحال والاسواق
انتقلت الاضرابات والاحتجاجات بقوه الى
عدد من الجامعات الايرانيات حيث نظمت الله
بعض الجامعات كجامعه امير كبير في العاصمه
طهران تجمعنا احتجاجيا رددوا فيها شعارات
طبعا
هذا للنظام ايضا في جامعات بمناطق كردستان
وبلوستان والاحواز ردد المحتجون فيها شعار
المراه الحياه الحريه اضافه ايضا لشعار
الموت لخميني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الان الى مونديال قطر 20 22 حيث يشهد يوم
غد الجمعه عوده للمباريات بعد استراحه
يومين مباريات دور ربع النهائي ستكون
بقمتين امريكيتين اوروبيتين بتلعب
البرازيل مع كرواتيا وبعدها الارجنتين مع
هولندا التي تعمل في ان تغير ذكر خيبه
نهائيات 2014 حين انتهى مشوارها عند نصف
النهائي على يد الارجنتين لمتابعه ايضا
الاجواء في الدوحه
بخارج اطار الملاعب ينضم الينا ليث بزاري
موفد العربيه الى هناك ليس هذين اليومين
كانت استراحه من المباريات ولكن الحياه
والفعاليات لم تتوقف في الدوحه هل يمكن ان
تطلعنا على هذه الاجواء وماذا يقوم به
المشجعون هذه الايام
نعم ميسون يقومون باشياء كثيره
يقومون بالمتابعه الفن والثقافه واكتشاف
معالم قطر السياحيه عندما لا يكون هناك
مباريات بين المنتخبات المتنافس للفوز
بكاس العالم 2022 يعني الحفلات والموسيقى
والتي تسمع هنا في الدوحه كثيره ان كانت
اجنبيه عربيه
اغنيتك المميز نعم هاي حبينا اليوم نستضيف
الشاب خالد ما الوراء هذه الاغنيه الموجود
معنا في التاسعه الليله مساء الخير مساء
النور
[موسيقى]
يعني في الجزائر
لم يشارك المنتخب
المغرب شفنا اول امبارح
انت كنت في المباراه
همم
اللقاء مع مع اسبانيا يعني وكنت يعني وكنا
كنا عصبيين انا شفت شفت الملعب هذه الملعب
كان كله بالاحمر كله مغربي يعني ما كنتش
ما كنتش متصور يعني نشوف الحاره قد قديش
المغرب يعني يعني اللي اول مره ان شاء
الله ان شاء الله يكون عندهم يعني الفوز
وكل المغرب العربي الكبير
فخور وفرحان وشوفنا الجزائر
ان شاء الله تكون عندنا عرس كبير ان شاء
الله اكيد مشاهدين على العربيه
ههه
[ضحك]
الاغنيه اللي هي كلهم فرحانين بهاي اسئله
كبيره الله الله ههه
كل العالم العربي وكل العالم ايضا يحب
الشاب خالد واغانيه وموسيقى الرائعه جدا
اتفضل شاب خالد
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
المغربيه ومشجع كل يعني يعني ان شاء الله
نكون موجود في الملعب ونكون كذلك ان شاء
الله يكون عندنا فرحه كبيره ان شاء الله
النصر وبنكر المونديال ليش لا الكاس
العالم
بالكواليس موجود
عنده فعاليات كثير من الفنانين العرب
عندنا كاظم الساهر جاي قريبا نانسي
اغار منك والاجواء اللي بتضلك عايشه
والله العظيم
قلت لك باللي عندي احمد شوقي عندها اغنيه
جديده كده عملناها انا وياك ديمانتيس اورو
ان شاء الله تكون عجبتكم الجمهور ان شاء
الله على كل حال احنا بانتظار على احر من
الجمر المباراه بين البرتغال والمغرب ان
شاء الله يفوز الفريق المنتخب المغربي لما
يكون بطل العالم الدوحه
طفله سوريه تتمنى للحاقه بوالدها المتوفي
بسبب الالم الذي وصلت اليه هي وافراد
عائلتها لفقدانهم الدفء والغذاء خاصه مع
بدايه فصل الشتاء القادم
من الشمال السوري شرحت واقعها المرير عبر
تسجيل المصور لينتشر الفيديو بشكل واسع
يا عم كل يوم جوعانين
انا بابا شهيده قبل ما يموت كان عندنا على
طول حطب كان يدفينا على طول كانه دفيانين
على زمان بابا بس هلا
[موسيقى]
كل شيء خرا
صار بابا بمحل ونحن احنا شو ذنب
الاطفال
على اتفاقيه الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله
بين البلدين
ولي العهد السعودي والرئيس الصينيه يشهد
ان التوقيع على اتفاقيات بين البلدين
وترقب قلمتين عربيه وخليجيه مع الصين
نجاح الوساطه التي قادها ولي العهد
السعودي ورئيس الاماراتي تبادل سجينين
اثنين بين واشنطن وموسكو
وبعد احباط انقلاب الرايخ داخليه المانيا
تدعو لاعاده النظر في المؤسسات الامنيه
[موسيقى]